hello beautiful how are you i'm good how
are you i'm good i don't know whether to
call you gaga or patricia though anymore
you are uh you are her i'm gaga
um are we gaga and gucci tonight uh no
tonight i'm wearing armani
we loved the other day you revealed that
the inaugural gown you wore which was
spectacular was bulletproof can you tell
me a secret about the outfit tonight uh
well it's not bulletproof
uh and it's uh very tight
and so i'm wearing nine corsets
and uh welcome to the premiere
is nine for real uh no
but i'm so excited to be here tonight i
grew up really close to lincoln center
and i used to come listen to wynton
marsalis play the
trumpet and i'm just really honored to
be here tonight you know we know what a
proud new yorker you are and we actually
wanted to ask you there's an incredible
scene in the movie where patrizia comes
for the fake gucci bag she says why are
we letting this happen but look have you
ever did you ever go to canal street and
never buy a fake bag
who didn't
we all did i have a fake louie i do but
it's not fake
tell me what's the secret just watch the
film i've seen it oh you well they're
like it's pretty good it's pretty good
stuff replicas as al pacino says
and i feel so honored to be on screen
with al pacino with all these great
actors this is an incredible cast
do you remember what your fake bag was
gucci
[Laughter]
i love it um jeremy was just telling me
that you guys had some incredible
dinners and that at one dinner al was
chasing you around a table and jack said
that you you kind of stayed in character
for a lot of it what were those cast
dinners like in italy you know i won't
reveal those private moments if uh the
the gentlemen would like to talk about
those private moments they can uh but i
will say this al pacino is a legend and
he changed the landscape of acting and
cinema and uh
our secrets are our secrets and i love
him very much um
can we ask really quick just loved that
you gave britney spears the shout out on
instagram she is free we wondered you've
been such a champion for her have you
talked to her and could we ever see you
two do a collab now that she's more on
her own i don't like to speak about my
private relationships with people but
what i would say is this
i think that mental health is important
and should not be used against anyone uh
i care for her and i wish her all the
best and
i'm so happy that she gets to have the
future that she wants now well after
sharing her hero healing after sharing
the screen with al we want to see you
keep acting of course what do you want
to do next and who do you want to share
a screen with in future um i have a lot
in mind and i will keep it to myself
[Music]
you